- Witaj ponownie w kursie Rozumienie Informacji
i Obliczeń Kwantowych.
Mam na imię John Watrous i
jestem dyrektorem technicznym IBM Quantum Education.
To jest szósta lekcja z serii i druga lekcja
w drugiej jednostce, która dotyczy algorytmów kwantowych.
W poprzedniej lekcji omówiliśmy model zapytań
obliczeń i zobaczyliśmy, że w tym modelu algorytmy kwantowe mogą
zapewnić uderzającą przewagę
nad algorytmami klasycznymi, w tym wykładniczą przewagę w przypadku problemu Simona.
Niestety model zapytań
nie ma żadnego bezpośredniego ani natychmiastowego
praktycznego znaczenia.
Pojęcie czarnej skrzynki okazuje się być bardzo użyteczną
abstrakcją, ale musimy trochę popracować, jeśli chcemy zastosować
spostrzeżenia, które zdobyliśmy z modelu zapytań, do bardziej standardowego środowiska obliczeniowego, gdzie dane wejściowe są podawane jako ciągi bitów
a nie jako wyrocznie czy czarne skrzynki.
Głównym celem tej lekcji jest stworzenie fundamentu,
dzięki któremu możemy to osiągnąć.
Oto przegląd lekcji. Przez większą jej część będziemy skupiać się
na koszcie obliczeniowym,
czyli innymi słowy, jak trudne są różne
zadania obliczeniowe i jak możemy mierzyć tę trudność.
Mówiąc w przybliżeniu, przekłada się to na to, jak długo czekamy
na zakończenie obliczeń i ostatecznie które
problemy obliczeniowe
możemy rozwiązać, a które
są poza naszym zasięgiem.
Zaczniemy od
kilku przykładów: faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych i obliczania największego wspólnego
dzielnika, w skrócie NWD.
To są bardzo dobre przykłady ilustrujące
zasady leżące u podstaw, a oba są też
bardzo istotne dla algorytmu Shora, który omówimy w następnej lekcji,
więc z tych przykładów
wyciągniemy podwójną korzyść.
Następnie ogólniej omówimy pojęcie kosztu obliczeniowego i to, jak możemy go mierzyć.
Istnieje wiele różnych
sposobów na to, ale skupimy się dość
wąsko na tym, jak możemy to robić za pomocą modeli obliczeń opartych na circuit,
a konkretnie Boolean circuits
i quantum circuits.
Skupimy się tutaj na algorytmach, a nie na sprzęcie komputerowym na przykład, i będziemy bardziej zainteresowani
tym, jak koszty uruchomienia algorytmu skalują się w miarę wzrostu rozmiarów konkretnych instancji problemu, a nie tym, ile sekund,
minut lub godzin zajmuje
jakieś konkretne obliczenie.
Idea, która motywuje ten punkt widzenia, jest taka, że algorytmy mają
fundamentalne znaczenie.
Do dziś
uruchamiamy algorytmy opracowane
bardzo, bardzo dawno temu i zupełnie naturalnie będą one dalej używane
wobec coraz większych
instancji problemów na szybszym i bardziej niezawodnym sprzęcie w miarę rozwoju technologii.
A to, jak skalują się koszty, mówi nam bardzo wiele
o ich użyteczności i o tym, jak przydatne będą w przyszłości.
W ostatniej sekcji lekcji zwrócimy się ku krytycznie ważnemu zadaniu, jakim jest uruchamianie obliczeń klasycznych
na komputerach kwantowych. Powód, dla którego jest to ważne, nie polega na tym, że mamy nadzieję zastąpić komputery klasyczne
komputerami kwantowymi,
co wydaje się niezwykle mało prawdopodobne w najbliższym czasie, jeśli w ogóle kiedykolwiek nastąpi, ale raczej dlatego, że otwiera to
wiele interesujących możliwości
dla algorytmów kwantowych.
Konkretnie, gdy tylko wiemy, jak uruchamiać obliczenia klasyczne
na komputerach kwantowych, stają się one dostępne dla algorytmów kwantowych jako podprocedury,
dzięki czemu możemy efektywnie
wykorzystać wszystko, co wiemy o algorytmach klasycznych, w dążeniu do kwantowych przewag obliczeniowych.
Komputery klasyczne, które mamy dzisiaj, są prawdziwymi cudami technologii.
Są niesamowicie szybkie, ale nie tak szybkie, by żaden problem obliczeniowy
nie był poza ich zasięgiem.
Niektóre problemy obliczeniowe
są tak inherentnie trudne, że choć mamy
algorytmy do ich rozwiązania, żaden komputer na planecie Ziemia dzisiaj
nie jest wystarczająco szybki, aby uruchomić te
algorytmy do końca nawet dla umiarkowanie dużych danych wejściowych w ciągu życia człowieka,
ani nawet w ciągu
całego życia Ziemi.
Żeby wyjaśnić to szerzej, przyjrzyjmy się
problemowi faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Sformułowanie problemu jest bardzo proste. Dane wejściowe to liczba całkowita N większa lub równa dwa, a wynikiem jest
rozkład N na czynniki pierwsze,
co oznacza listę pierwszych czynników N wraz z potęgami, do których te liczby pierwsze muszą być podniesione,
aby przez ich wymnożenie
otrzymać N.
Oczywiście czynniki pierwsze możemy mnożyć w dowolnej kolejności, ale pomijając kolejność,
rozkłady na czynniki pierwsze są zawsze jedyne dla każdego wyboru N.
Fakt ten nazywa się
zasadniczym twierdzeniem arytmetyki i jeśli chcesz dowiedzieć się o nim więcej, możesz go znaleźć
na samym początku
wielu książek z teorii liczb.
Jako bardzo prosty przykład, oto rozkład na czynniki pierwsze
liczby 12.
To dwa do potęgi dwa
razy trzy do potęgi jeden.
Nic dziwnego, że
komputer może powiedzieć ci to w mgnieniu oka, po prostu iteracyjnie szukając czynników pierwszych.
Oto kolejny przykład. Nie będę próbował odczytać tej liczby.
To około 3,4 kwatuordecyliona i muszę przyznać, że dziwi mnie, że istnieje nawet taka nazwa,
ale tak czy owak, ma 46 cyfr dziesiętnych i tu widzisz
jej rozkład na czynniki pierwsze.
Komputer może ci to też podać. Sfaktoryzowałem tę liczbę używając metody faktoryzacji zawartej w bibliotece matematyki symbolicznej dla Pythona,
i zajęło to kilka sekund, co nie jest szczególnie długim czasem, ale było wyczuwalne opóźnienie.
I z pewnością metoda factor_N nie znajduje tego rozkładu na czynniki pierwsze przez naiwne szukanie czynników pierwszych.
Faktycznie używa hybrydowego zestawu różnych algorytmów, w tym jednego zwanego algorytmem kolorowych wierszy, który jest algorytmem faktoryzacji
bardziej wyrafinowanym niż naiwne iteracyjne szukanie czynników pierwszych, i choć ta liczba może wydawać się dość duża,
jako dane wejściowe do problemu obliczeniowego wcale nie jest taka duża.
To tylko 46 znaków.
Oto jeszcze jeden przykład. To liczba z 309 cyframi dziesiętnymi.
Jeśli zapiszemy ją w notacji binarnej, ma 1024 bity i dlatego nazywa się RSA1024.
Rozkład tej liczby na czynniki pierwsze nie jest obecnie znany.
Liczba ta pochodzi z
wyzwania faktoryzacyjnego RSA, które było prowadzone przez RSA
Laboratories od 1991 do 2007 roku.
Oferowali nagrody pieniężne
za rozkłady na czynniki pierwsze różnych liczb o rosnącym
rozmiarze, w tym tej, która warta była 100 000 dolarów,
ale ta nagroda nigdy nie została odebrana.
Bezpieczeństwo systemu kryptografii
z kluczem publicznym RSA opiera się na trudności
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Jeśli potrafisz faktoryzować, możesz
złamać system, więc celem wyzwania było w zasadzie śledzenie
stanu wiedzy w zakresie faktoryzacji.
Wniosek jest taki, że
sfaktoryzowanie tej liczby jest poza naszymi obecnymi możliwościami.
O ile wiemy, sam
problem jest zbyt złożony dla komputerów klasycznych,
żeby rozwiązać go w praktyce.
Największa liczba wyzwania RSA, która dotychczas została sfaktoryzowana, przy okazji, ma 250 cyfr dziesiętnych.
Może być trochę trudno
to odczytać na ekranie, ale oto rozkład na czynniki pierwsze RSA250.
Dokonano tego w 2020 roku za pomocą algorytmu zwanego sitem ciała liczbowego, i był to zbiorowy wysiłek obejmujący dziesiątki tysięcy
komputerów na całym świecie.
Teraz rozważmy inny
problem obliczeniowy, którym jest problem obliczania największego wspólnego
dzielnika, w skrócie NWD,
dwóch nieujemnych liczb całkowitych.
Oto sformułowanie problemu. Dane wejściowe tym razem składają się z dwóch
liczb, N i M,
i zakładamy, że
nie są obie równe zero.
Celem jest obliczenie
NWD tych dwóch liczb, czyli największej liczby całkowitej D, która dzieli bez reszty zarówno N, jak i M,
i jeśli pomyślisz o
rozkładach na czynniki pierwsze N i M, odkryjesz, że NWD jest iloczynem wszystkich liczb pierwszych,
które dzielą zarówno N, jak i M, podniesionych do minimum z potęg występujących w dwóch
rozkładach na czynniki pierwsze.
Jest więc powiązany z problemem
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych, ale okazuje się być znacznie, znacznie łatwiejszy
do rozwiązania dla komputerów. Możemy obliczać NWD dla liczb z wieloma tysiącami cyfr
w mgnieniu oka.
Pokazywanie ci przykładów na ekranie nie ma sensu, bo moglibyśmy wypełnić
cały ekran cyframi i wciąż opisywalibyśmy
łatwo rozwiązywalne instancje tego problemu.
Ale jeśli jesteś zainteresowany, kliknij link w opisie wideo do strony podręcznika tej lekcji, gdzie znajdziesz komórki kodu
do tego rodzaju obliczeń,
o których mówię, w tym takich, które obliczają
NWD dużych liczb, i możesz je samodzielnie wypróbować.
Pytanie brzmi: dlaczego możliwe jest tak łatwe obliczanie NWD?
A odpowiedź na to pytanie jest taka, że mamy efektywne
algorytmy do obliczania NWD.
Wśród nich jest algorytm Euklidesa, odkryty ponad 2000 lat temu, ale istnieją też inne
efektywne algorytmy NWD.
I oczywiście mówimy tu o algorytmach klasycznych, co prowadzi do kolejnego pytania.
Czy mógłby istnieć efektywny
klasyczny algorytm faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych,
który pozwoliłby nam faktoryzować liczby takie jak RSA1024
w mgnieniu oka?
I odpowiedź brzmi: tak. Absolutnie mógłby istnieć efektywny klasyczny
algorytm faktoryzacji i obecnie nie znamy żadnego sposobu,
żeby wykluczyć tę możliwość. Możemy jedynie powiedzieć, że jeszcze takiego nie znaleźliśmy.
Dla wszystkich klasycznych
algorytmów faktoryzacji, które znamy, wciąż w zasadzie
szukamy czynników,
co sprawia, że liczby takie jak
RSA1024 są poza naszym zasięgiem.
Efektywne algorytmy NWD
z drugiej strony po prostu nie działają w ten sposób.
Nie szukają one
największego wspólnego dzielnika. Efektywnie po prostu go
konstruują za pomocą mechanicznej procedury o koszcie mniej więcej porównywalnym
do przemnożenia tych samych
dwóch liczb, i powiem o tym trochę więcej później w tej lekcji.
Oczywiście, to wszystko prowadzi do
algorytmu Shora, który zobaczymy w następnej lekcji — efektywnego algorytmu kwantowego
do obliczania rozkładów na czynniki pierwsze, ale mamy jeszcze trochę gruntu do przebycia zanim tam dotrzemy.
Następnie porozmawiamy
o matematycznej strukturze, za pomocą której możemy mierzyć koszty obliczeniowe
różnych algorytmów,
w tym tych, o których już mówiliśmy.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, skupimy się bardzo wąsko na circuit, co jest tylko małym wycinkiem
znacznie szerszego tematu.
Zacznijmy od bardzo ogólnego spojrzenia na zwykłe obliczenia
z poprzedniej lekcji, co oznacza w szczególności, że nie myślimy
o problemach zapytań,
ale o problemach, gdzie dane wejściowe
są podawane wprost jako ciąg binarny.
Jak powiedziałem w poprzedniej lekcji, moglibyśmy oczywiście dopuszczać
inne symbole, gdybyśmy chcieli, ale dla uproszczenia trzymajmy się ciągów binarnych
zarówno dla danych wejściowych, jak i wyjściowych.
Same obliczenia mogą być modelowane lub opisane na różne sposoby, takie jak model obliczeniowy maszyny Turinga,
Boolean circuits, quantum circuits lub programy napisane
w języku takim jak Python czy innym języku według twojego wyboru.
Jak powiedziałem chwilę temu, skupimy się na
circuit — Boolean i quantum.
Najpierw poświęćmy jeszcze trochę czasu na omówienie danych wejściowych i wyjściowych, które zakładamy są ciągami binarnymi.
Używając ciągów binarnych, możemy kodować wiele różnych rodzajów
obiektów matematycznych, takich jak liczby, wektory,
macierze, grafy,
opisy cząsteczek na przykład, a także listy wszystkich tych obiektów i innych.
Jako bardzo prosty przykład, jeśli chcemy kodować nieujemne
liczby całkowite jako ciągi binarne, możemy użyć notacji binarnej.
W tej tabeli zobaczysz pierwsze 13
nieujemnych liczb całkowitych wraz z ich binarnymi
reprezentacjami, czyli kodowaniami.
W trzeciej kolumnie widzisz długość
każdego z tych kodowań, czyli całkowitą liczbę bitów potrzebnych do kodowania,
a oto prosty wzór, który dokładnie mówi ci, ile bitów
potrzeba ogólnie dla dowolnej nieujemnej liczby całkowitej N.
Zwróć uwagę w szczególności, że
długość kodowania jest generalnie znacznie mniejsza
niż sama liczba.
Jest logarytmiczna względem liczby.
RSA1024 na przykład ma kodowanie o długości 1024, ale sama liczba jest
oczywiście znacznie większa.
Ten schemat kodowania działa
dla nieujemnych liczb całkowitych, ale jeśli chcemy obsługiwać
dowolne liczby całkowite, w tym ujemne, możemy
po prostu dołączyć bit znaku.
Możemy też dopuścić dowolną liczbę zer wiodących w tych kodowaniach, jeśli chcemy, żeby kodowania
wypełniały blok bitów lub rejestr o stałym rozmiarze,
o ile jest wystarczająco duży. Czasami jest to bardzo wygodne.
Nie jest to jedyny sposób kodowania liczb całkowitych jako ciągów bitów.
Istnieją inne sposoby, by to zrobić, ale jest to dość
standardowy sposób.
Dla innych rodzajów obiektów, które mogą być wejściem lub wyjściem
interesujących nas problemów obliczeniowych, możemy wymyślić
inne schematy kodowania.
Na przykład, pomyśl o tym, jak
mógłbyś zakodować wektor lub graf jako ciąg binarny, albo pomyśl, jak mógłbyś zakodować
dwa ciągi binarne
w jeden ciąg binarny używając tylko symbolu zero i jeden, bez spacji czy innego symbolu
do oddzielenia dwóch ciągów. Z pewnością istnieją sposoby, żeby to zrobić, i w rzeczywistości mamy dużą swobodę
co do tego, jak dokładnie to robimy.
Często nie będzie jednego standardowego ani powszechnie uzgodnionego sposobu kodowania tego, o czym mówimy,
jako ciąg binarny,
ale to jest w porządku — możemy po prostu wybrać jeden lub wymyślić nowy, jeśli wolimy.
Z czysto formalnego punktu widzenia myślimy o obliczeniach jako zasadniczo mechanicznych transformacjach na ciągach bitów,
a szczegóły dotyczące używanych przez nas
schematów kodowania są z pewnością ważne na pewnym poziomie.
Niemniej jednak, gdy projektujemy i
analizujemy algorytmy, zazwyczaj nie martwimy się zbytnio o szczegóły
schematów kodowania.
Jeśli poprosisz dwie różne osoby o opracowanie sposobu kodowania, powiedzmy, cząsteczek pewnego
rodzaju jako ciągów binarnych,
możesz spodziewać się, że wymyślą różne sposoby, ale jeśli to byłyby rozsądne osoby, które wiedzą, co robią,
możesz też rozsądnie oczekiwać, że tłumaczenie między tymi dwoma schematami kodowania byłoby dość
prostym procesem obliczeniowym,
najprawdopodobniej wymagającym bardzo
prostego obliczenia, które byłoby dość łatwe w porównaniu z właściwym obliczeniem,
które nas interesuje.
Wniosek jest taki, że szczegóły dotyczące używanych schematów kodowania są często dość drugorzędne, a nasz nacisk jest na
samych algorytmach.
Nic z tego nie będzie problemem w tej lekcji, nawiasem mówiąc. Będziemy skupiać się głównie na problemach dotyczących liczb całkowitych, które zakładamy są kodowane binarnie,
ale warto o tym wiedzieć.
Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, dla dowolnego rodzaju rozważanego problemu, długość wejścia odnosi się
do liczby bitów potrzebnych do zakodowania wejścia,
i traktujemy długość wejścia jako rozmiar instancji rozważanego przez nas problemu.
Teraz rozważmy
same obliczenia, które są reprezentowane przez
niebieski prostokąt na tym rysunku.
Sposób, w jaki będziemy mierzyć
koszt tych obliczeń, polega na zliczaniu liczby elementarnych operacji, których wymagają.
Intuicyjnie rzecz biorąc, elementarna operacja to taka, która angażuje małą, stałą
liczbę bitów lub qubit
i może być wykonana szybko i łatwo, na przykład obliczenie iloczynu AND
dwóch bitów.
Na poziomie formalnym
istnieją różne sposoby definiowania elementarnej operacji, w zależności od tego, jakiego
modelu obliczeniowego używamy.
Na przykład elementarną operacją może być jeden krok maszyny Turinga, gdybyśmy używali tego modelu.
Na potrzeby tej lekcji skupimy się na modelach circuit, jak już wspomniałem, a konkretnie na quantum
i Boolean circuits.
Pracując z circuit, typowo traktujemy każdy gate jako reprezentację elementarnej operacji.
Do tej pory w serii widzieliśmy kilka różnych quantum gates,
w tym bramki X, Y i Z, bramki Hadamard, bramki S i T,
bramki controlled NOT, bramki swap, bramki Toffoli i bramki Fredkina.
Mówiliśmy też o query gates w kontekście modelu zapytań, ale nie będziemy pracować w modelu zapytań w tej lekcji, więc nie będziemy się martwić
o query gates na razie.
Widzieliśmy też, że dowolna unitarna operacja na dowolnej liczbie qubit
może być traktowana jako gate, jeśli chcemy.
Na potrzeby mierzenia kosztu jednak nie będzie to zbyt pomocne, więc po prostu
wybierzemy zestaw gate
i uznamy ten zestaw za nasz zestaw elementarnych operacji.
Po pierwsze, uwzględnimy
unitarne bramki jednego qubit, które tu widzisz,
czyli bramki X, Y i Z,
bramki Hadamard oraz bramki S i T, a także ich odwrotności
lub sprzężone transpozycje.
W rzeczywistości nie potrzebujemy wszystkich tych gate. Gdy tylko mamy bramki Hadamard i T, możemy zaimplementować resztę,
ale dla wygody uwzględnimy je wszystkie.
Uwzględnimy też bramki controlled NOT i to będą jedyne
bramki wieloqubitowe w naszym zestawie.
Na koniec uwzględnimy pomiary standardowej bazy jednego qubit, żeby z naszych circuit
mogły wychodzić klasyczne informacje.
Jeśli skupimy się tylko na unitarnych gate i na chwilę zapomnimy o
pomiarach, otrzymamy tzw.
uniwersalny zestaw gate.
Oznacza to, że
dowolna unitarna operacja na dowolnej liczbie qubit może
być zaimplementowana dokładnie
lub dowolnie blisko
za pomocą quantum circuit zbudowanego z tych gate.
Innymi słowy, jest to
wystarczający zestaw gate, z których możemy zbudować dowolną unitarną
operację.
Niekoniecznie dokładnie, ale możemy uzyskać dowolnie dobre
przybliżenie.
Może to wymagać wielu gate, i nie jest aż tak trudno wykazać, że niekiedy konieczna jest ich duża liczba,
niemniej jednak jest to zawsze możliwe.
Udowodnienie, że jest to uniwersalny zestaw gate, nie jest jednak prostą sprawą i nie omówimy, jak się to robi, w tej serii,
ale jest to dość dobrze znany fakt i istnieją różne
sposoby jego udowodnienia.
Istnieją też inne zestawy gate, które są czasem używane
zamiast tego, takie jak bramki Toffoli, bramki Hadamard i bramki S wraz z pomiarami,
ale jest to dość standardowy wybór.
Podsumowując, to są
operacje kwantowe, które uznamy za elementarne.
Dla Boolean circuits
będziemy traktować te cztery gate jako
operacje elementarne: bramki AND, bramki OR, bramki NOT i FANOUT.
FANOUT, nawiasem mówiąc, nie jest zawsze liczony jako gate, ale w naszym przypadku ważne jest, żebyśmy to zrobili, jak zobaczymy później w lekcji.
Podobnie jak w przypadku naszego standardowego zestawu quantum gate, ten zestaw jest nieco nadmiarowy.
Nie potrzebujesz zarówno AND, jak i OR. Możesz tworzyć jedno z drugiego za pomocą trzech bramek NOT,
ale uwzględnienie obu nie szkodzi i jest po prostu wygodne.
Jak zapewne wiesz, jest to uniwersalny zestaw gate
do obliczeń deterministycznych, co oznacza, że dowolna funkcja
z bitów na bity
może być zaimplementowana za pomocą Boolean circuit złożonego z gate z tej kolekcji.
Tak jak w przypadku quantum circuits, nie oznacza to, że każda funkcja może być efektywnie zaimplementowana
przez Boolean circuit,
i rzeczywiście większość funkcji
może być zaimplementowana tylko za pomocą bardzo dużych circuit
z prostego powodu, że funkcji jest wiele, wiele
i nie wszystkie mogą mieć małe circuit. Po prostu nie ma dość małych circuit dla wszystkich.
Udowodnienie uniwersalności jest łatwiejsze
w tym przypadku niż w przypadku kwantowym, jak się okazuje.
Więc jeśli jeszcze nie wiesz, jak to udowodnić, zastanów się nad tym
i sprawdź, czy możesz to rozgryźć, jeśli masz taką ochotę.
Teraz, gdy zdecydowaliśmy, które
gate dopuszczamy i które
uznajemy za elementarne operacje, możemy zastanowić się, ile z nich
jest potrzebnych do wykonania
różnych obliczeń.
Żeby to zrobić, będziemy używać
tej definicji rozmiaru circuit.
Ta definicja działa zarówno dla
Boolean, jak i quantum circuits i jest bardzo prosta.
Rozmiar circuit to
całkowita liczba gate, które zawiera.
Na przykład, jeśli wrócimy
do tego samego przykładu, który widzieliśmy kilka razy — naszego Boolean circuit do obliczania sumy wykluczającej XOR dwóch bitów,
widzimy, że ma rozmiar siedem,
bo jest siedem gate: dwie bramki FANOUT, dwie bramki NOT,
dwie bramki AND i jedna bramka OR. Gdybyśmy zdecydowali nie liczyć
bramek FANOUT, co jest powszechne, miałoby rozmiar pięć,
ale my będziemy liczyć bramki FANOUT, więc jego rozmiar wynosi siedem.
Rozmiar circuit
odpowiada liczbie elementarnych operacji,
które musimy wykonać.
Więc gdybyśmy wykonywali
te operacje sekwencyjnie, rozmiar mówiłby nam, jak długo by to trwało,
dlatego możesz myśleć o rozmiarze circuit jako reprezentacji sekwencyjnego czasu wykonania.
W ten sposób będziemy
mierzyć koszt obliczeniowy na potrzeby tej lekcji.
Istnieje jednak inna właściwość
circuit, która może być też traktowana jako czas
potrzebny do uruchomienia circuit — jest nią głębokość circuit.
Precyzyjnie rzecz biorąc, głębokość
to maksymalna liczba gate napotkanych na jakiejkolwiek ścieżce od drutu wejściowego do drutu wyjściowego,
co jest równoważne liczbie warstw gate potrzebnych
do stworzenia circuit, gdzie warstwa to zbiór gate,
które mogą być wykonywane jednocześnie, ponieważ nie mają
żadnych wspólnych drutów.
Na przykład nasz circuit
z poprzedniego przykładu ma głębokość cztery i widzimy bezpośrednio z diagramu, że są cztery warstwy.
Bramki FANOUT mogą być
wykonywane jednocześnie, bramki NOT mogą być
wykonywane jednocześnie i bramki AND mogą być
wykonywane jednocześnie.
Możemy więc myśleć o głębokości circuit jako reprezentacji równoległego czasu wykonania.
Głębokość circuit jest z pewnością interesującym i ważnym pojęciem i istnieją bardzo
zaawansowane techniki, które można zastosować, by zmniejszyć
głębokość wymaganą dla niektórych obliczeń — niekiedy wręcz dramatycznie — ale jest to zaawansowany temat
i nie powiemy zbyt wiele więcej o nim w tej serii.
Więc jeszcze raz, będziemy
mierzyć koszt obliczeniowy w kategoriach rozmiaru circuit, czyli innymi słowy,
liczby elementarnych operacji potrzebnych do wykonania obliczeń.
Na początku lekcji mówiliśmy o problemie
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych i zobaczyliśmy, że czas potrzebny algorytmowi do rozwiązania tego problemu
może rosnąć wraz z długością danych wejściowych, i zazwyczaj
to właśnie na tym się skupiamy
analizując algorytmy.
Czyli interesuje nas, jak koszty uruchamiania algorytmów skalują się w miarę wzrostu danych wejściowych.
Oczywiście ten rodzaj skalowania nie jest jedyną istotną rzeczą.
Na przykład możemy po prostu chcieć znaleźć czynniki
RSA1024 i tyle.
Więc w takim przypadku mówilibyśmy o
pojedynczej instancji problemu, gdzie nic nie rośnie.
Ale kiedy myślimy o algorytmach, sposób, w jaki skalują się ich koszty, ma ogromne znaczenie i mówi nam wiele
o algorytmach.
Ten punkt widzenia jest
spójny z ideą, że algorytmy są fundamentalne, i jak mówiłem wcześniej,
w miarę upływu czasu i postępu technologicznego będą uruchamiane
na coraz większych danych wejściowych.
Ale zauważ, że choć dane wejściowe do problemów obliczeniowych
mogą rosnąć, circuit nie rosną.
Każdy circuit ma stały rozmiar.
Dlatego, jeśli chcemy opisać
algorytm za pomocą circuit, faktycznie potrzebujemy rodziny circuit,
a przez rodzinę circuit rozumiemy kolekcję circuit, która staje się coraz większa, żebyśmy mogli obsługiwać dane wejściowe
w miarę ich wzrostu. Na przykład rozważmy klasyczny deterministyczny algorytm
do faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych — może oparty na próbnym dzieleniu, ale szczegóły nie mają większego znaczenia
dla tego przykładu.
Moglibyśmy w zasadzie
opisać taki algorytm za pomocą rodziny Boolean circuits, gdzie jeśli chcemy faktoryzować liczbę,
której binarna reprezentacja ma N bitów, bierzemy circuit CN z naszej rodziny i wpisujemy liczbę,
którą chcemy faktoryzować,
do bitów wejściowych tego circuit.
Czasem możemy chcieć parametryzować te
circuit w różny sposób, więc może nie zawsze być tak, że N-ty circuit ma N bitów wejściowych,
ale jest to dość typowy sposób. Naturalnie, w miarę wzrostu długości danych wejściowych, spodziewalibyśmy się, że circuit
w tej rodzinie będą coraz większe,
co odzwierciedla fakt, że
faktoryzacja czerobitowych liczb jest znacznie łatwiejsza niż faktoryzacja 1024-bitowych.
Mając to na uwadze, mierzymy koszt takiego
algorytmu za pomocą funkcji, która mówi nam, ile
elementarnych operacji
potrzebujemy dla każdej możliwej długości danych wejściowych — i możemy to robić zarówno dla algorytmów klasycznych, jak i kwantowych.
Jako przykład rozważmy problem dodawania liczb całkowitych, który z pewnością jest znacznie
prostszy niż faktoryzacja
czy nawet obliczanie NWD.
Dla uproszczenia załóżmy, że zarówno N, jak i M są nieujemnymi liczbami całkowitymi i że są reprezentowane
przez ciągi binarne o tej samej długości.
Jak moglibyśmy zbudować Boolean circuits do dodawania tych dwóch liczb?
Zacznijmy od algorytmu — standardowego algorytmu dodawania, który jest binarnym analogiem metody,
którą, jak zakładam, wszyscy nauczyliśmy się do dodawania liczb ołówkiem na kartce papieru: zaczynamy od
najmniej znaczących bitów,
dodajemy je razem i to daje nam najmniej
znaczący bit wyniku wraz z bitem przeniesienia,
który musimy uwzględnić
przechodząc do następnej pozycji. Kontynuujemy przesuwanie się przez bity, generując bity wyjściowe
wraz z bitami przeniesienia,
aż dojdziemy do końca.
Ta metoda może być
wyrażona dość bezpośrednio za pomocą Boolean circuits.
Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o tym jest zaczęcie od małego circuit do dodawania dwóch jednobitowych liczb całkowitych.
Da nam to liczbę
między zerem a dwa, gdzie mniej znaczący bit jest sumą XOR bitów wejściowych,
a bardziej znaczący bit, czyli bit przeniesienia, jeśli wolisz, jest iloczynem AND dwóch bitów wejściowych.
Czasem odnosimy się do circuit, który wykonuje te
dwie operacje razem, jako do półsumatora.
To działa dobrze, gdy
są tylko dwa bity wejściowe, ale jeśli chcemy dodawać liczby całkowite z więcej niż jednym bitem każda,
będziemy musieli
jakoś poradzić sobie z bitami przeniesienia.
Możemy więc kaskadowo złożyć
dwa półsumatry i wziąć sumę OR
bitów przeniesienia, które generują, żeby stworzyć tzw. pełny sumator,
który jest zasadniczo Boolean circuit do dodawania trzech jednobitowych
liczb razem.
A mając pełny sumator, możemy dodawać liczby razem
po prostu przez kaskadowanie — od najmniej znaczącego bitu
do najbardziej znaczącego. W zasadzie implementujemy standardowy algorytm dodawania używając pełnych sumatorów do
obsługi bitów przeniesienia.
Jaki jest więc koszt tych obliczeń?
Potrzebujemy siedmiu elementarnych
gate dla każdej bramki XOR, co oznacza 10 gate dla półsumatora,
a zatem 21 gate dla pełnego sumatora, czyli dwa półsumatry plus jedna bramka OR.
Na koniec, jeśli nasze liczby wejściowe mają AND bitów, potrzebujemy półsumatora dla
najmniej znaczącego bitu
i pełnego sumatora dla każdego pozostałego bitu, a wynikiem końcowym jest 21 razy N minus jeden plus 10, czyli 21N minus 11 gate łącznie.
Gdybyśmy z jakiegoś powodu nie chcieli
liczyć bramek FANOUT i uwzględnili bramki XOR w naszym zestawie gate, potrzebowalibyśmy 5N minus
trzy gate łącznie.
Miło wiedzieć dokładnie, ile gate lub elementarnych operacji jest potrzebnych do wykonania różnych obliczeń,
tak jak właśnie zobaczyliśmy przy dodawaniu liczb całkowitych.
I oczywiście, jeśli faktycznie chcemy implementować te obliczenia, musimy znać te szczegóły.
Ale jeśli zawsze wchodzimy w takie szczegóły, zwłaszcza w przypadku bardziej
skomplikowanych algorytmów, szybko zagrzęźniemy w szczegółach,
które w wielu przypadkach mają
drugorzędne znaczenie.
Jednym ze sposobów uproszczenia spraw, bardzo powszechnym w
analizie algorytmów, jest stosowanie notacji dużego-O,
która pozwala nam wyrażać
i porównywać tempa wzrostu w dość prosty sposób,
co jest bardzo wygodne.
A oto definicja leżąca u podstaw tej notacji.
Załóżmy, że mamy
dwie funkcje G i H, które możemy traktować jako przyjmujące wartości nieujemnych liczb całkowitych dla uproszczenia,
choć tak naprawdę nie jest to wymagane. Może G i H reprezentują koszty różnych obliczeń, na przykład.
Mówimy wtedy, że G jest dużym-O z H, co tradycyjnie zapisujemy
ze znakiem równości jak tutaj.
Jeśli G(N) wynosi co najwyżej pewna
dodatnia stała C razy H(N), o ile N jest wystarczająco duże.
Chodzi więc o to, co
dzieje się, gdy N jest duże.
Formalnie, „wystarczająco duże" oznacza, że istnieje pewien wybór N zero taki, że nierówność jest spełniona
ilekroć N jest co najmniej N zero.
Kluczem jest to, że te
liczby C i N zero są stałe.
Mogą być dowolnymi liczbami,
ale cokolwiek nimi są, nie mogą się zmieniać w miarę wzrostu N.
Jeśli nigdy wcześniej nie widziałeś
takiej definicji, może wymagać trochę przyzwyczajenia i możesz znaleźć zasoby,
które wyjaśnią tę koncepcję
w znacznie większych szczegółach,
niż jestem w stanie w tej lekcji.
Zazwyczaj wybieramy
funkcję H, żeby była prosta, w celu wyrażenia czegoś o tym, jak szybko rośnie funkcja G.
Na przykład funkcja, której wartością jest 17 razy N do sześcianu minus 257
razy N do kwadratu plus
65 537, jest dużym-O z N do sześcianu, i możesz dopasować ten
przykład do definicji
wybierając odpowiednie C i N zero.
Na przykład, jeśli weźmiemy C równe 18, to rzeczywiście będziemy mieć, że wyrażenie wynosi co najwyżej 18 razy N do sześcianu,
o ile N jest wystarczająco duże.
Łącząc tę notację z
przykładem dodawania liczb całkowitych, możemy teraz powiedzieć, że istnieje rodzina Boolean circuits
do dodawania nieujemnych liczb całkowitych taka, że rozmiar N-tego circuit, czyli tego, który działa
dla danych wejściowych długości N,
jest dużym-O z N. Faktyczny rozmiar CN
według naszej analizy wynosił 21 razy N minus 11,
ale to jest duże-O z N.
Nie zawsze jest mądrze odrzucać takie szczegóły, ale tutaj ma to sens,
ponieważ ujawnia istotną naturę standardowego algorytmu dodawania: jego koszt skaluje się liniowo
względem rozmiaru dodawanych liczb, a to wyrażenie nie jest wrażliwe na niektóre niskopoziomowe
szczegóły naszego modelu,
takie jak to, które gate dokładnie uznajemy za elementarne operacje.
Na przykład, gdybyśmy zdecydowali, że bramki XOR powinny być uznane za
elementarne operacje, lub że bramki FANOUT nie powinny
liczyć się jako gate, lub obu tych rzeczy razem,
nadal mielibyśmy, że dodawanie liczb całkowitych można obliczyć przy koszcie dużym-O z N.
Oto kolejny przykład
problemu obliczeniowego: mnożenie liczb całkowitych.
Podobnie jak przy dodawaniu, możemy zapytać, jaki jest koszt
tych obliczeń.
Jeśli rozważymy standardowy
algorytm mnożenia, czyli binarny analog metody mnożenia liczb
nauczanej w szkole podstawowej,
który polega zasadniczo na
przesunięciu i dodawaniu, gdy pracujemy z liczbami w binarnym, odkrywamy, że istnieją Boolean circuits o rozmiarze dużym-O z N do kwadratu
do mnożenia N-bitowych liczb całkowitych.
Nie będę przez to przechodzić szczegółowo. Oczywiście circuit są
trochę bardziej skomplikowane niż te dla dodawania, ale jeśli pomyślisz o sposobie,
w jaki działa standardowy
algorytm mnożenia, nie powinno to być zaskoczeniem.
Zasadniczo musimy
wykonać mniej więcej N dodawań, z których każde ma koszt liniowy, co daje nam
łącznie koszt kwadratowy.
Można to uogólnić. Jeśli jedna liczba ma N bitów, a druga M bitów, potrzebujemy circuit
o rozmiarze dużym-O z N razy M.
Przy okazji, tu używamy rozszerzenia notacji dużego-O, gdzie mamy wiele zmiennych, ale można ją rozszerzyć w ten sposób,
i jeśli interesują cię konkretne szczegóły, odsyłam do treści podręcznika
do tej lekcji, który jest znowu podlinkowany w opisie wideo.
W rzeczywistości możliwe jest
mnożenie dwóch N-bitowych liczb całkowitych w sposób
asymptotycznie lepszy od standardowego algorytmu mnożenia.
W szczególności algorytm mnożenia Schönhage-Strassen
mnoży dwie N-bitowe liczby całkowite przy koszcie dużym-O z
N razy logarytm N
razy logarytm logarytmu N. Więc gdy N staje się duże, jak
dziesiątki tysięcy bitów,
jest to faktycznie bardziej
efektywny sposób mnożenia, ale jest skomplikowany i narzut sprawia, że jest niepraktyczny
dla mniejszych liczb.
Dodajmy więc mnożenie
do naszej listy przykładów.
I dla uproszczenia, podajmy koszt wynikający ze standardowego algorytmu mnożenia, który wynosi duże-O z N do kwadratu.
Więc znowu skupiamy się na zasadniczej naturze tego kosztu, którą jest to, że skaluje się kwadratowo
lub podkwadratowo, jeśli używamy asymptotycznie lepszych metod.
Możemy też rozważyć
problem dzielenia liczb całkowitych, który jest precyzyjnie sformułowany na ekranie.
Mówimy tu o obliczaniu ilorazu i reszty, więc odpowiedź składa się
z dwóch liczb całkowitych, Q i R.
Znowu istnieje standardowy
algorytm dzielenia, który ma też koszt kwadratowy, i podobnie jak przy mnożeniu,
istnieją faktycznie
algorytmy asymptotycznie lepsze.
Jak więc wypadają algorytmy NWD w porównaniu?
Cóż, okazuje się, że algorytm Euklidesa ma koszt kwadratowy, i to właśnie miałem na myśli wcześniej w lekcji, kiedy mówiłem, że możemy obliczać NWD
przy mniej więcej takim samym koszcie, jak mnożenie dwóch liczb razem.
Znowu istnieją
algorytmy asymptotycznie lepsze, podobnie jak dla
dodawania i mnożenia,
choć koszt jest nieco
wyższy w tym przypadku, przynajmniej o ile wiemy.
Wspomnę jeszcze jeden przykład problemu do tej listy, a jest nim potęgowanie modularne.
Tu mamy trzy liczby
wejściowe, K, M i N, a celem jest obliczenie
N do potęgi K modulo M,
co oznacza resztę
po podzieleniu przez M.
Nie jest to wcale oczywiste, ale możemy obliczyć potęgowanie modularne przy koszcie qubit, czyli dużym-O z N do sześcianu
dla N-bitowych liczb całkowitych.
Sposób na to nie polega na tym, żeby najpierw obliczyć N do potęgi K, a potem obliczyć resztę.
Nawet zapisanie N do potęgi K mogłoby wymagać wykładniczo wielu bitów, więc to podejście nie zadziała.
Zamiast tego możemy użyć algorytmu
zwanego algorytmem potęgowania, zwanego też wielokrotnym kwadrowaniem, gdzie wszystko jest robione modulo M
i używamy bitów
K do iteracyjnego kwadratowania i mnożenia w sposób,
który sprawia, że wszystko działa.
Jest więc bardziej
kosztowny niż inne, ale wciąż możemy wykonywać
potęgowanie modularnie dość szybko dla liczb
z wieloma tysiącami bitów.
Jak więc koszty tych zadań wypadają w porównaniu z faktoryzacją liczb całkowitych?
Jeśli zacznemy prosto i
pomyślimy o próbnym dzieleniu, gdzie najpierw sprawdzamy, czy dwa jest czynnikiem liczby wejściowej,
a następnie sprawdzamy trzy i tak dalej, skończymy z dość
kosztownym algorytmem: dużym-O z N do kwadratu razy
dwa do potęgi N nad dwa.
Każde dzielenie zajmuje czas kwadratowy i w najgorszym przypadku będziemy musieli szukać czynników pierwszych aż do pierwiastka kwadratowego z liczby wejściowej,
i stąd pochodzi N
nad dwa. Jeśli w tym momencie nie znaleźliśmy
czynnika pierwszego, możemy zatrzymać, bo wtedy
sama liczba wejściowa musi być pierwsza.
Jest to niezwykle kosztowne, ponieważ N pojawia się jako wykładnik w tym wyrażeniu, co oznacza, że ten
algorytm ma koszt wykładniczy.
Dla kontrastu, wszystkie przykłady, które mamy w tym polu, mają to, co nazywamy kosztem wielomianowym, gdzie N jest podnoszone do potęgi,
ale ta potęga jest zawsze stałą liczbą, która nie rośnie w miarę
wzrostu długości danych wejściowych.
W tych przypadkach potęgi
to jeden, dwa i trzy.
Wrócę do wielomianowego versus wykładniczego kosztu za chwilę, ale najpierw dokończmy
to, co wiemy o faktoryzacji.
Wcześniej wspomniałem
o sicie ciała liczbowego, które jest najlepszym
algorytmem faktoryzacji pod względem sposobu skalowania jego kosztu.
W rzeczywistości koszt tego algorytmu nie jest rygorystycznie udowodniony, bo jest powiązany z pewnymi otwartymi pytaniami z teorii liczb,
ale domniemywa się, że ma
koszt wyglądający tak.
Tym razem duże-O jest w wykładniku, ale zamiecę ten
szczegół pod dywan.
Kluczowy wniosek jest taki, że jest znacznie lepszy
od próbnego dzielenia, bo choć N pojawia się w wykładniku,
jest podniesione do potęgi 1/3 i to przekłada się na znacznie niższy koszt i dlatego ten algorytm
może obsługiwać liczby takie jak RSA250, podczas gdy próbne dzielenie z pewnością nie może.
Jest jednak nadal wykładniczy w tym sensie, że potęga N pojawia się w wykładniku, więc w rezultacie
nadal nie może obsługiwać
liczb takich jak RSA1024.
Teraz powiem trochę więcej o koszcie wielomianowym
versus wykładniczym.
Mówimy, że algorytm
ma koszt wielomianowy, jeśli jego koszt jest dużym-O z N do potęgi B,
gdzie B może być dowolną dodatnią liczbą, ale kluczowe jest to, że B musi być stałe, co oznacza, że nie zmienia się
w miarę wzrostu długości wejścia N.
W przykładach, które widzieliśmy chwilę temu, czyli dodawania, mnożenia, dzielenia liczb całkowitych, obliczania NWD
i potęgowania modularnego,
mieliśmy B równe
jeden, dwa lub trzy.
Więc to wszystkie
algorytmy o koszcie wielomianowym.
Ale mówiąc ogólnie o koszcie wielomianowym, B może być dowolną dodatnią liczbą.
Może być nawet milion,
ale musi być stałe.
Jako bardzo przybliżone uogólnienie, algorytmy o koszcie wielomianowym
są zazwyczaj traktowane jako reprezentujące efektywne algorytmy.
To zdecydowanie uproszczenie, ale jako przybliżona wskazówka, możesz myśleć o algorytmie o koszcie wielomianowym
jako o czymś, co w jakiś sposób korzysta
ze struktury problemu, żeby zbudować rozwiązanie, w przeciwieństwie do podejścia metodą brute force
lub wyczerpującego przeszukiwania
bardzo dużej przestrzeni.
Oczywiście algorytm, którego koszt skaluje się jak N do miliona
dla danych wejściowych długości N,
rozsądnie rzecz biorąc nie byłby
traktowany jako efektywny i nie spodziewalibyśmy się być w stanie uruchomić go dla dużych danych wejściowych.
Ale nawet algorytm N do miliona musi robić coś sprytnego, co w jakiś sposób odzwierciedla strukturę
rozwiązywanego przez niego problemu, żeby uniknąć wykładniczego skalowania kosztów, które byłoby związane z
wyczerpującym przeszukiwaniem dużej dziedziny.
W praktyce identyfikacja algorytmu o koszcie wielomianowym jest naprawdę tylko pierwszym
krokiem ku efektywności.
Jeśli problem jest ważny
i ktoś odkryje pierwszy algorytm o koszcie wielomianowym dla niego, może mający bardzo duży wykładnik,
możesz być dość pewny, że projektanci algorytmów
znajdą ulepszenia, które spowodują obniżenie tego wykładnika.
Zasadniczo możesz
myśleć o istnieniu algorytmu o koszcie wielomianowym
dla problemu jako o zademonstrowania wykonalności
rozwiązania tego problemu
dla rozsądnie dużych danych wejściowych, ale wciąż może być dużo pracy potrzebnej, żeby osiągnąć prawdziwą efektywność.
W teorii złożoności, typowo mówi się, że koszt algorytmu
skaluje się podwykładniczo, jeśli koszt jest dużym-O z dwa do potęgi N
do potęgi epsilon dla każdej dodatniej liczby rzeczywistej epsilon, a jeśli nie jest podwykładniczy,
to jest wykładniczy, albo może być nawet nadwykładniczy, jak dwa do dwa do N,
co jest podwójnie wykładnicze,
ale o ile wyjście
nie jest nadwykładniczo długie, każdy problem może faktycznie być
obliczony przez Boolean circuit
o koszcie wykładniczym, jak się okazuje. Więc ważne rozróżnienie jest tutaj między kosztem wielomianowym
i wykładniczym.
Nie znamy żadnych klasycznych algorytmów o podwykładniczym koszcie dla
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Na przykład koszt sita ciała liczbowego nie jest dużym-O z dwa do N do epsilon, gdy epsilon wynosi 1/3 lub mniej,
więc nie spełnia tej definicji.
To bez wątpienia bardzo sprytny algorytm, ale nadal jest sitem i nadal w efekcie przeszukujemy
bardzo dużą przestrzeń w celu identyfikacji czynników danej liczby.
Jak zobaczymy w następnej lekcji, istnieje faktycznie kwantowy algorytm o koszcie wielomianowym
do faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Algorytm Shora ma koszt wielomianowy i konkretnie ma koszt qubit, podobny do potęgowania modularnego.
Inną klasą problemów, którą możesz znać, jest klasa problemów NP-zupełnych.
Nie będę wchodzić w to, czym są problemy NP-zupełne w tej lekcji, ale możesz je poszukać, jeśli jesteś zainteresowany.
Domniemywa się, że
żaden z tych problemów nie ma kosztu podwykładniczego.
To zasadniczo oparta na circuit wersja tego, co jest czasami nazywane
hipotezą czasu wykładniczego, ale jak dotąd nikomu nie udało się
udowodnić, jak to zrobić.
Właściwie nie możemy nawet udowodnić, że nie istnieją algorytmy o koszcie liniowym dla problemów NP-zupełnych.
Jest to po prostu naprawdę trudne, przynajmniej o ile wiemy, żeby wykluczyć możliwość przyszłego odkrycia niesamowicie kreatywnego
algorytmu dla tych problemów.
Oto rysunek
ilustrujący związek między kosztem wielomianowym i wykładniczym.
Na osi X mamy długość danych wejściowych dla dowolnego rozważanego przez nas problemu, a oś Y reprezentuje
koszt rozwiązania tego problemu,
albo możesz myśleć o tym
jako o czasie potrzebnym do rozwiązania problemu, jeśli wolisz.
Algorytm o koszcie wykładniczym
może skalować się tak.
Dla krótkich danych wejściowych koszt może nie być szczególnie wysoki, na przykład faktoryzacja
liczby 12,
ale w miarę wydłużania się danych wejściowych koszt w końcu eksploduje.
Algorytm o koszcie wielomianowym
z drugiej strony może skalować się tak.
Koszt będzie generalnie nadal wzrastał w miarę wydłużania się danych wejściowych i może nawet kosztować więcej niż algorytm o koszcie wykładniczym dla niektórych danych wejściowych,
ale w końcu będzie
znacznie mniej kosztowny niż algorytm wykładniczy i nie eksploduje w ten sam skrajny sposób,
jak algorytmy o koszcie wykładniczym.
Wyobraź sobie więc, że
mamy jakiś maksymalny koszt, który chcemy ponieść, lub maksymalny czas, który chcemy czekać na odpowiedź,
jeśli wolisz myśleć o czasie, to algorytm o koszcie wykładniczym będzie działał tylko dla danych wejściowych
do pewnej długości,
podczas gdy generalnie algorytm o koszcie wielomianowym pozwoli nam rozwiązać
problem dla większych danych wejściowych.
I dlatego na przykład możemy łatwo obliczać NWD dla liczb z wieloma tysiącami
bitów, ale w najgorszym przypadku
nie możemy faktoryzować liczb tego rozmiaru.
W ostatniej części lekcji zwrócimy uwagę na implementowanie obliczeń klasycznych
na komputerach kwantowych.
Konkretnie zobaczymy, że każde obliczenie, które może być wykonane przez Boolean circuit, może być też wykonane przez quantum circuit
przy mniej więcej takim samym koszcie. Co więcej, można to
zrobić w sposób czysty, który jest ważny, gdy chcemy uruchamiać te obliczenia
jako podprocedury w ramach
większych obliczeń kwantowych, i wyjaśnię, co rozumiem przez czysty, gdy zagłębimy się dalej w dyskusję.
Będziemy używać
bramek Toffoli w tym procesie.
Przypomnij sobie, że bramki Toffoli to bramki controlled-controlled-NOT, więc ich działanie na stanach bazy standardowej
jest takie, jak widzisz tutaj na ekranie.
Zauważ też, że możemy
myśleć o bramkach Toffoli jako o query gates
dla funkcji AND.
To nie znaczy, że są query gates w dosłownym sensie. Jak wspomniałem na początku lekcji, nie pracujemy teraz w modelu zapytań,
ale raczej ich działanie podąża za tym samym wzorcem, co query gate.
Możemy myśleć o wartościach binarnych A i B jako o wejściach do funkcji AND i jak w query gate,
te wartości są przekazywane
jako część wyjścia, a wartość funkcji, czyli logiczny AND z A i B,
jest XORowany na dolny qubit. Nie uwzględniliśmy bramek Toffoli w naszym standardowym zestawie gate.
Moglibyśmy zmienić zdanie, jeśli chcielibyśmy, ale naprawdę nie musimy
tego robić, bo alternatywnie możemy implementować bramki Toffoli za pomocą bramek Hadamard,
bramek T i T-dagger
i bramek controlled NOT, jak tu widzisz.
Nie jest wcale oczywiste,
że ten konkretny circuit implementuje bramkę Toffoli, ale tak jest, i możesz mi po prostu uwierzyć na słowo,
albo samodzielnie wszystko wymnożyć, żeby poćwiczyć, albo możesz zapytać Qiskit lub Pythona,
czy dowolne oprogramowanie mnożące macierze, żeby zrobiło mnożenie za ciebie.
Możesz sprawdzić
treść podręcznika do tej lekcji, żeby zobaczyć, jak to zrobić za pomocą Qiskit.
Teraz możemy przejść do symulowania Boolean gates za pomocą quantum circuits i wszystko, czego potrzebujemy do tego, to bramki NOT,
bramki controlled NOT i bramki Toffoli.
Te operacje są wszystkie deterministyczne oprócz tego, że są unitarne i czasem opisujemy
takie operacje jako odwracalne, i w rzeczywistości
badanie odwracalnych obliczeń poprzedza obliczenia kwantowe i stamtąd pochodzi cała
ta procedura.
Boolean gates, o które musimy się martwić, to bramki NOT, bramki Hadamard i bramki FANOUT,
i pokażemy, że możemy implementować te gate, czyli symulować je, jeśli wolisz, za pomocą bramek NOT,
bramek controlled NOT i bramek Toffoli.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, chcemy
quantum circuits, które pozwalają nam obliczać wartości Boolean gates, które właśnie wymieniłem,
gdy damy im jako wejście qubity
w stanach bazy standardowej.
Dla dowolnych stanów kwantowych wejściowych działanie będzie wyznaczone
przez liniowość, jak zwykle.
Nie musimy robić niczego
specjalnego z bramkami NOT. Bramki NOT to bramki NOT i mogą być implementowane bezpośrednio.
A bramki OR mogą być symulowane
za pomocą bramek Toffoli i NOT.
Bramki AND są łatwe, szczególnie w świetle tego, co powiedziałem chwilę temu o bramkach Toffoli, które zasadniczo są
implementacjami query gate
dla funkcji AND.
Precyzyjnie rzecz biorąc, możemy wprowadzić nowy qubit inicjalizowany do stanu zero
i sprawić, żeby ten qubit był
celem naszej bramki Toffoli, a dwa wejściowe
qubity były kontrolerami.
Dodatkowym qubitom takim jak ten, które często są wprowadzane
do obliczeń kwantowych, nadawane są różne nazwy — ja będę je nazywał qubitami przestrzeni roboczej.
Nasze typowe założenie dotyczące qubitów przestrzeni roboczej jest takie, że zaczynają w stanie zero i często możemy je
zwrócić do stanu zero po zakończeniu, ale nie zawsze.
Na diagramie mamy ket zero wewnątrz przerywającego prostokąta, żeby wskazać, że inicjalizacja tego qubitu
jest częścią procesu, i jeśli nie masz
świeżego qubitu takiego jak ten, nie będziesz
w stanie przeprowadzić tej symulacji.
Dolny wyjściowy qubit
jest tym, na którym nam zależy, bo to jest wynik
operacji AND i w zasadzie
skończyliśmy z pozostałymi dwoma
więc mogą zostać w pudełku.
W rzeczywistości możesz nawet wyobrazić sobie, że pozbycie się tych dwóch qubitów jest częścią zadania
symulacji tej bramki AND,
coś w rodzaju śmieci, które
trzeba posprzątać.
Ale tak czy owak, w ten sposób
możemy symulować bramkę AND.
Teraz, gdy wiemy, jak robić bramki AND, możemy robić bramki OR za pomocą
jednego z praw De Morgana.
Jeśli umieścisz bramki NOT na dwóch wejściach i wyjściu bramki AND,
dostaniesz bramkę OR — proste.
A ostatni jest FANOUT — do tego potrzebujemy tylko bramki controlled NOT wraz z qubitem przestrzeni roboczej.
Konkretnie, jeśli
ustawimy qubit przestrzeni roboczej jako cel, efektywnie po prostu kopiujemy dowolny stan bazy standardowej, który wpływa,
co działa jak bramka FANOUT.
Mamy więc wszystkie nasze gate.
A teraz, gdy mamy wszystkie nasze gate, możemy przejść do circuit.
Załóżmy, że mamy
jakiś Boolean circuit o nazwie C — może to być dowolny
Boolean circuit, który wybierzesz,
o ile jest złożony z
bramek AND, NOT i FANOUT.
Niech T będzie liczbą gate w C, a nazwiemy F funkcję, którą oblicza C.
Możemy więc myśleć o F jako mającej postać, którą widzisz tu, gdzie N jest liczbą wejściowych bitów C,
M jest liczbą wyjściowych bitów, a sigma jest alfabetem binarnym.
Co robimy, to po prostu przechodzimy po jednym przez gate C.
Pozostawiamy bramki NOT bez zmian i zastępujemy pozostałe symulacjami,
które właśnie opisałem.
Więc jeśli C wygląda tak, to co otrzymujemy to circuit
R wyglądający tak.
Na tym diagramie wszystkie
qubity przestrzeni roboczej, których potrzebujemy do symulacji, zostały wyjęte z ich pudełek i zebrane na dole.
K to całkowita liczba
qubitów przestrzeni roboczej, których potrzebujemy — jeden dla każdego gate C z wyjątkiem bramek NOT.
Na wyjściu R mamy qubity, które
odpowiadają wyjściu C, i tutaj te qubity
są pokazane na górze,
choć po zakończeniu wszystkiego nie będzie tak naprawdę ważne, czy są na górze, czy nie.
Precyzyjnie rzecz biorąc, zakładając, że uruchomiliśmy R na stanie bazy standardowej odpowiadającym
dowolnemu N-bitowemu ciągowi X,
te M wyjściowych qubitów będzie w stanie bazy standardowej
odpowiadającym F(X).
Mamy też wszystkie pozostałe qubity z bramek AND i OR.
Musimy je jeszcze uwzględnić, i gdy zbierzemy je wszystkie razem, będą w jakimś stanie bazy standardowej.
Niezależnie od tego, jaki jest ten stan bazy standardowej, musi być on pewną funkcją ciągu X — nazwiemy
tę funkcję G.
G jest więc nową funkcją, która jest
wyznaczona przez gate C i mówi nam, w jakim stanie
są te pozostałe qubity
po uruchomieniu R. G jest następną literą po F — to jeden powód, żeby nazwać tę funkcję G,
ale innym powodem, żeby ją tak nazwać, jest to, że G pochodzi od garbage, czyli śmieci.
To wszystkie są qubity-śmieci, a w szczególności mamy
dwa qubity-śmieci dla każdej bramki AND i każdej bramki OR.
Całkowita liczba gate,
których potrzebujemy, jest dużym-O z T.
Bo dla każdego gate C potrzebujemy ograniczonej liczby quantum gates.
Bramka OR jest najdroższa. Do niej potrzebujemy trzech bramek NOT wraz z jedną bramką Toffoli,
a bramka Toffoli kosztuje nas 15 gate z naszego standardowego zestawu gate.
Więc to co najwyżej 18 gate
w R dla każdego gate C.
Gdybyś chciał to zoptymalizować, mógłbyś, ale na potrzeby
przybliżonej analizy asymptotycznej, możemy po prostu powiedzieć, że
R ma duże-O z T gate.
Udało nam się więc
obliczyć tę samą funkcję F, którą obliczał oryginalny Boolean
circuit C,
i zrobiliśmy to przy koszcie liniowym względem rozmiaru C.
Jeśli zależy nam tylko na
obliczeniu tej funkcji F, to gotowe.
Niestety, mamy
te qubity-śmieci i będą one generalnie rujnować
wzorce interferencji, które sprawiają, że algorytmy kwantowe działają, jeśli spróbujemy użyć tego
circuit R jako podprocedury
wewnątrz większego algorytmu kwantowego.
Możemy jednak faktycznie pozbyć się tych śmieci — sposobem na to jest skorzystanie z faktu, że circuit R może być odwrócony,
czyli innymi słowy, możemy
uruchomić go w odwrotnej kolejności.
Żeby zilustrować, jak to działa, wyobraźmy sobie, że najpierw uruchamiamy R, a potem uruchamiamy R w odwrotnej kolejności,
co możemy wyrazić jako R-dagger.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, oznacza to, że stosujemy gate
R w odwrotnej kolejności i bierzemy odwrotności
każdego z gate.
Bramki NOT, bramki controlled NOT
i bramki Toffoli są faktycznie swoimi własnymi odwrotnościami, więc jeśli myślimy w kategoriach tych gate,
to R-dagger jest naprawdę po prostu R z gate podanymi
w odwrotnej kolejności.
Ale ogólnie rzecz biorąc, zawsze możemy uruchamiać dowolny unitarny quantum circuit w odwrotnej kolejności w opisany przeze mnie sposób,
czyli stosujemy gate
w odwrotnej kolejności i zastępujemy każdy z poszczególnych gate jego odwrotnością.
Gdybyśmy to zrobili, odkrylibyśmy, że najpierw uruchomienie R, a potem uruchomienie R w
odwrotnej kolejności, nie robi nic.
Więc gdybyśmy zaczęli w stanie bazy standardowej, jak tu mamy, to skończylibyśmy dokładnie w tym samym stanie bazy standardowej.
Oczywiście samo to
nie jest zbyt pomocne, ale możemy wprowadzić zestaw dodatkowych qubitów, a konkretnie
M qubitów, gdzie M jest liczbą wyjściowych bitów circuit C.
Te dodatkowe qubity mogą
być w dowolnym stanie kwantowym, ale żeby wyjaśnić, jak to działa, założymy, że są w stanie bazy standardowej
odpowiadającym pewnemu ciągowi Y. Y jest więc M-bitowym ciągiem, i możemy
wykonać zestaw bramek controlled NOT,
jak tu widzisz, co efektywnie XORuje ciąg F(X)
na ciąg Y przechowywany
w tych dolnych M qubitach.
Wyjście
całych obliczeń jest więc takie, jak pojawia się na ekranie.
X i Y są dowolnymi ciągami binarnymi. X ma M bitów, a Y ma M bitów, i potrzebujemy też K qubitów przestrzeni roboczej.
Gdy uruchamiamy R, obliczamy F(X) i ten ciąg jest przechowywany
w górnych M qubitach, ale mamy też zestaw qubitów-śmieci,
więc XORujemy wyjście F(X) na dolne M qubitów, a potem uruchamiamy R w odwrotnej kolejności
żeby posprzątać śmieci.
Powinienem zaznaczyć, że ważne jest, żeby R był deterministyczny.
Gdyby te górne M qubitów mogło być zamiast tego w jakiejś superpozycji
stanów bazy standardowej, to nie działałoby poprawnie,
ale działa, gdy
R jest deterministyczny.
Więc jeśli porównamy quantum
circuit, który właśnie zbudowaliśmy, z oryginalnym Boolean circuit C, widzimy, że działa zasadniczo
w ten sam sposób,
w jaki działa query gate
dla dowolnej funkcji. Jest tu pewna różnica, polegająca na tym, że potrzebujemy
tych qubitów przestrzeni roboczej, żeby wszystko działało, ale w inny sposób efektywnie zbudowaliśmy query gate
lub query circuit dla funkcji, którą oblicza C.
Udało nam się też, nawiasem mówiąc, zwrócić qubity przestrzeni roboczej do ich stanu początkowego, więc mogą one w zasadzie być ponownie używane
jako qubity przestrzeni roboczej
dla kolejnych obliczeń.
Możemy, jeśli chcemy, umieścić ramkę wokół całego quantum circuit i nazwać go Q, a związek z
C staje się wtedy jaśniejszy.
Circuit Q będzie
generalnie większy niż C. Potrzebujemy kilku quantum
gate w Q dla każdego gate C,
i potrzebujemy też bramek controlled NOT
w środku, ale liczba jest nadal
liniowa względem rozmiaru C.
Należy też zauważyć, że jest to całkowicie ogólna procedura, która działa dla dowolnego Boolean circuit, i wcale nie próbowaliśmy optymalizować Q.
Dla konkretnego circuit C może bardzo dobrze istnieć
sposób na zmniejszenie rozmiaru Q, a to obejmuje metody
zmniejszające liczbę
qubitów przestrzeni roboczej, jeśli jest to coś, co chcemy zrobić — i to jest procedura uruchamiania
obliczeń klasycznych
na komputerze kwantowym.
Jest to dość proste, ale to ważna
rzecz, którą warto umieć robić.
W szczególności, teraz gdy
wiemy, jak to zrobić, możemy swobodnie korzystać z dowolnych obliczeń klasycznych,
wewnątrz obliczeń kwantowych, pod warunkiem, że stosujemy tę formę, gdzie dane wejściowe są przekazywane, a wyjście jest XORowane
na zestaw qubitów,
tak jak mieliśmy dla query gates.
Koszt skaluje się liniowo. Więc na przykład możemy
tworzyć quantum circuits dla problemów takich jak dodawanie liczb całkowitych,
mnożenie, dzielenie, obliczanie NWD i potęgowanie modularne, i wszystko to może być zrobione przy tym samym asymptotycznym koszcie
co dla Boolean circuits.
Potrzebujemy do tego qubitów przestrzeni roboczej, ale przynajmniej są dostępne do ponownego użycia, gdy skończymy.
Jedna ostatnia uwaga, którą warto wspomnieć, jest taka, że ta metoda daje nam sposób na implementowanie query gates,
na co napomknąłem w poprzedniej lekcji.
Mianowicie, jeśli mamy algorytm zapytań, który przyjmuje pewną funkcję F jako wejście i mamy sposób na obliczenie
F za pomocą Boolean circuit,
możemy użyć tej procedury, żeby zbudować query gate dla tej funkcji, a potem uruchomić nasz algorytm zapytań.
Czy jest to przydatne, zależy od samego problemu zapytań i tego, co próbujemy osiągnąć, ale w istocie ta
konstrukcja daje nam
sposób na połączenie modelu zapytań z bardziej standardowym modelem obliczeń.
To w pewnym sensie, jak działa algorytm Shora do faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Będziemy budować
quantum circuits jak ten z niektórych operacji arytmetycznych, o których mówiliśmy wcześniej w lekcji.
Budując je w ten sposób,
dajemy quantum circuits możliwość ewaluowania tych operacji na superpozycjach stanów klasycznych.
I jak zobaczymy, to pozwala nam
efektywnie faktoryzować liczby całkowite.
To koniec tej lekcji, która skupiała się głównie na ustanowieniu fundamentu
dla algorytmów kwantowych w standardowych ramach obliczeniowych bez czarnej skrzynki.
Mówiliśmy o kosztach obliczeniowych głównie przez pryzmat problemów związanych z podstawową teorią liczb.
Omówiliśmy koszt wielomianowy
versus wykładniczy dla zadań obliczeniowych i zobaczyliśmy, jak obliczenia klasyczne
mogą być implementowane przez quantum circuits w czysty, wolny od śmieci sposób, który pozwala na ich użycie jako podprocedur
wewnątrz większych obliczeń kwantowych.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na następnej lekcji, gdzie zobaczymy, jak algorytm Shora wykorzystuje te idee, pozwalając nam na faktoryzację
liczb całkowitych przy koszcie wielomianowym.
Do zobaczenia.